often will think of money as having
power in and of itself
um
it does not money is uh is information
and it does not have power in and of
itself
[Music]
i think the cryptocurrency thing is an
interesting
approach to
reducing the um
error in the
the database that is called money
um
you know i think i have a pretty deep
understanding of the of what money
actually is on a practical day-to-day
basis because of paypal um
you know i really
got in deep there um
and
right now the money system actually for
practical purposes is
is really a bunch of uh heterogeneous uh
mainframes running old cobalt
okay you mean literally that's literally
that's literally what's happening in
batch mode
okay in patch mode yeah uh pretty the
poor fastest who have to
maintain that code okay that's a
that's a pain that's pain not even for
trans cobalt yep that's cobalt it's like
and they still
banks are still buying mainframes in
2021 and running ancient cobalt code
uh and uh you know the the federal
reserve is like probably even older than
the what the banks have and they have an
old cobalt mainframe
and so now
and so the the government effectively
has editing privileges on the on the
money database
and they use those editing privileges to
make more money
whenever they want
and this increases the error in the
database that is money so i think money
should really be viewed through the lens
of information theory
and uh and so it's uh
you're kind of like uh like an internet
connection like what's the bandwidth uh
you know
total bit rate uh what is the latency
jitter
uh packet drop uh you know
errors in errors in the network uh
communication
just think money like that basically
um i think that's probably right where
you think of it
and and then say what what system uh
from an information theory standpoint
allows an economy to function the best
uh
and
you know um
crypto is an attempt to reduce the
the error uh in
uh in money that is contributed by
uh governments uh
diluting the money supply
as basically a pernicious pernicious
form of taxation
so both policy in terms of with
inflation and actual like technological
cobalt like cryptocurrency takes us into
the 21st century in terms of the actual
systems that allow you to do the
transaction to store wealth all those
kinds of things
like i said just think of money as
information people um often will think
of money as having power in and of
itself
um
it does not money is uh is information
and it it does not have power in and of
itself
uh
the like the again applying the physics
tools of thinking about things in the
limit
is helpful if you are stranded on a
tropical island um and uh
you have a trillion dollars it's useless
because there's no there's no resource
allocation
money is a database resource allocation
but there's no resources to allocate
except yourself
so money is useless
um
uh
if you're surrounded on desert island
with
no food you'd uh all the bitcoin in the
world
will
not stop you from starving yeah
so
um
so like just think of money as as a
database for resource allocation um
across time and space
and
um and then what what what system
uh it is what what
in what form should that that
database or data system
what what would be most effective now
the there's a there is a fundamental
issue with um say bitcoin in its current
form
uh in that it's the transaction volume
is very limited
um
and uh the
latency
if the latency for for a properly
confirmed transaction is to is too long
much longer than you'd like
so it's not it's actually not great from
um
transaction volume standpoint or a
latency standpoint
so it is perhaps useful as
as to search to solve an aspect of the
money database problem
[Music]
which is a sort of store of wealth or an
accounting of
relative obligations i suppose
um but it is not useful as a
currency as a day-to-day currency but
people have proposed different
technological solutions
yeah lightning network and the layer two
technologies on top of that i mean it's
it's all it seems to be all kind of a
trade-off but the point is it's kind of
brilliant to say that just think about
information think about what kind of
database what kind of infrastructure
enables yeah like you're operating an
economy
um
and you need to have some
thing that
allows for the efficient
to have efficient uh value ratios
between products and services so you've
got this massive number of products and
services and you need to
you can't just bar barter it's like that
would be extremely unwieldy uh so you
need something that gives you
the the
ratio of exchange between goods and
services
um
and and then something that allows you
to
uh shift obligations across time like
debt debt and equity shift obligations
across time then what does what does the
best job of that
part reason why i think there's some
um merit to dogecoin even though it was
obviously created as a joke
um
is that it it actually does have a much
higher
uh transaction volume capability than
bitcoin um
and the you know the cut like the costs
of doing a transaction the the dodge
coin fee is is very low like right now
if you want to do a bitcoin transaction
the price of doing that transaction is
very high so you could not use it
effectively for most things
um and nor could it even scale to a high
volume
um
uh
and when bitcoin was you know started i
guess when around 2008 or something like
that um
the internet connections were much worse
than they are today like order of
magnitude
i mean there's the way way worse you
know in 2008 so so like having us you
know a small
uh block size or whatever is
you know and a long
synchronization time is
made sense in 2008 but did you know 2021
or fast forward 10 years it's like it's
it's like
comically low you know it's uh
so
um
and i think there's some
value to
having
a linear increase in the amount of
currency that uh is generated um
so because some amount of the currency
you'd like like
if if
a currency is too deflationary or like
or should say if if
if if a currency is expected to increase
in value over time there's reluctance to
spend it
because they're like oh if i
i'll just hold it and not spend it
because it's scarcity is increasing with
time so if i spend it now then i will
regress defending it so i will just you
know total it
um
but if there's
some dilution of the currency occurring
over time that's that's more of an
incentive to use that as a currency so
um those coins somewhat randomly has
uh
a
um
just a fixed a number of
of
sort of coins or hash strings that
uh are generated every year so there's
there's some inflation but it's not a
percentage base it's a it's so the
it's a fixed number so the percentage of
inflation will necessarily decline over
time um
so it just i i'm not saying that it's
like the ideal system for a currency but
i think it actually is uh just
fundamentally better than
anything else i've seen just by accident
um so i like how you said um around 2008
so you're not uh
you know some people suggested you might
be satoshi nakamoto you previously said
you're not i'm not
you're not for sure
would you tell us if you were yes okay
[Music]
you